معادله جدليه بين الرجال والنساء للكشف عن
مستوى التقارب والتباعد لدى خوض التحديات
تحت الفعل نتحدث مشاهدينا عن دراسه جديده
وجدت ان النساء اقل استعدادا للاقدام على
المخاطر والسبب هن اكثر حساسيه وشعورا
بالام الخساره من الرجال ما يعني ابعد عن
الشر او ابعد عن الشر وغني له احنا هدف
هذا هو عنواننا ومبدانا في الحياه على
الجانب الاخر استنتجت الدراسه البريطانيه
ان الرجال اكثر تفائلا بشكل واضح من
النساء ما يجعلهم اكثر استعداد للمخاطره
والتحدي على اساس هذه النتائج ربط باحثون
بين اداء الجنسين في قطاعات العمل مثلا
لهذا يكون الرجال اكثر قدره على الوصول
لمناصب لقدرتهم على تحمل عواقب قراراتهم
بينما النساء يضعن احتمالات متعدده
ويستبعدنا المخاطر كون شعورهن بالم
الفقدان مؤلم بشكل اكبر وفق هذه الدراسه
لان الناس في العراق ولبنان ايضا من لديه
قدره اكبر على خوض التحديات وتحمل الخساره
النساء ام الرجال ماذا اجابوا
السبب انه المراه
بدها كل شي بدها تحصل على كل شيء حاول
تعمل مشاكل حاول تشوف حالك تكبر برايي اني
انه الرجال اكثر تحدي لانه هو عنده قوه
وعنده يعني اكثر شيء يعني يقولون النجم
[موسيقى]
ابسط الامور يعني المراه تزعل من كل شيء
اذا نسى عيد ميلادها بالعراق يكونون
الرجال اكثر لانهم امكانيات المراه دائما
تكون محدوده بالعراق
[موسيقى]
الرجال اكثر بالتحدي ويقدر يتحمل خساره
وهذا المره ما بتقدر تفرض دغري لا الرجل
الرجل بيتعمل الرجل لا بيطلع بيفسح بروح
وبيجي بينسى المراه بالبيت بتحمل هم اكثر
لان كل شغل البعد عليها وكل شيء الرجال
بيطلع بيحكي مع اصحابه بينسى المراه اكثر
من الرجل ليش هذه المراه شغلت البيت
والشغل تربه الاولاد والاطفال والمدارس
والشغل كله الغسيل والطبخ والنفخ
مع بعض على الحلوه والمره مش بس على
الحلوه الخساره اثنيناتهم سوا اثنين
متساويين لانه المراه والرجل مكلفين
بالتشريف والتكليف الخساره بتحملها الرجال
اكثر اكيد لانه المسؤوليه على عاتقه يمكن
المراه بتعبر اكثر لهيك تتحمل اكثر اما
الرجل بخاف يبكي بيحبس يا قلبه
لذيذه ارائهم بس على فكره انا قلت لك عادل
انا عندي نظريه بهذا الموضوع هن طبعا
الدراسه بتقول انه هن ما وجدوا سبب محدد
للرجال يقدموا اكثر على اخذ المخاطر برايي
بانه الجواب بنقدر نلاقيه بعلم التطور
لانه لما كنا لمده ملايين من سنين لما كنا
عايشين
بمجتمعات صغيره انسان الغاب وانسان الكهف
كانت النساء تبقى في الكهف
دير بالها او يعني تنتبه على الاطفال
وتحميهم من المخاطر حيوانات مفترسه زواحف
ما الى ذلك والرجل الرجال كانوا يخرجوا
للصيد لو المراه ما كانت
عندها هذا الحس العالي للخطر وغير مقدمه
على اخذ المخاطر كان الاطفال ممكن ما قدرت
انها تحميهم وبالتالي هذا كان يعني فانا
البشريه في المقابل الرجل لو لم يتحلى
بهذا الحس انه هو مقدام ولا يخاف من الخطر
ومستعد انه ياخذ ريسكس مثلا كان ما خرج
للصيد كان هاي القبيله لم تاكل كنفنه
البشريه ايضا فاعتقد انه هذا نوع من انواع
الغريزه
صح
طيب مشاهدينا الان معنا في الاستوديو
الاختصاصي الدكتور محمد فريج اهلا بك
دكتور محمد
عجبتني اللي قالت بخاف يبكي
بخاف يبكي والله صراحه هذه ايضا بالثقافه
ان الرجل لا يبكي
يتحملوا التوازن كانها يعني كانت الفكره
براسي انه اللي بيحصل فعلا هو التوازن بين
الاقدام وايش نسميه الاحجام بالتفكير اللي
بيصير فعليا هذا هو وهذا اللي بيخلينا
نكمل بعض اذا بدنا نتكلم بحب اكثر اليوم
بتوافق اكثر لانه هذا الشيء اللي بيكمل
الرجل المراه
بيتكلموا عن عدم القدره على التحمل الالم
الخوف من الخساره طب والحمل والولاده شو
بيكون
اعتقدوا عن الم نفسي لدراسه تتحدث مش عن
الالم الجسدي عن الالم النفسي نتيجه
للخساره الماديه تحديدا اعتقد اكثر
انه هذه الدراسات جيده انها تكون محدده
اذا تكلم
انه ليش رجال اكثر تفاؤلا على كيف راح
يكون وضعهم المادي كمان سنه من النساء
لانهم ببالغوا بتقدير قدراتهم وتقديرهم
لذاتهم بينما النساء بالعكس عدد مجحفين
بحق نفسهم مش انا اللي بقول للدراسه
كبيره جدا وهو قاعد يعطي نفسها امل
فبالتالي ليش نعتبرها لكن اللي بيصير هون
بالدراسه في خسائر وصار في نتائج مترتبه
على هذا التفاؤل ان يحصل هناك خسائر اكبر
فاذا ويمكن هون صح التركيز كان اكثر على
الموضوع الدخل المتعلق بالاسر ال13 هل
ايضا جزء مما قال تراويه وجزء حتى مما
نعيشه انه التربيه تنعكس على انه المراه
دائما هي في
الجانب الخلفي للرجل
يعني يسندها محميه هذا لا يدفعها الى انه
تتحمل ايضا الضربات والخسائر من ناحيه
نفسيه انا طبعا هلا
او الحصانه طبعا هو شيء تراكمي وتعلمي
فطبيعي انه اي امراه واي رجل حتى لو كان
في تربيته لا يتحمل الالام او الخسائر مع
التربيه والتجربه يصير في عنده قدره على
التحمل وتفاهم اكثر ولكن كانهم بقولوا عن
الطبيعه الخلقه اصل الخلقه الفطره وكانه
رجل بطبيعته في نوع من المغامره
الشعور بالقدره على تحمل الخسائر بينما
الحسابات والواقعيه اذا بدنا نقول واقعيه
وكانها اكثر للمراه بتبين الدراسه
اكيد مش اي اشي مش في صالح الرجل مش راح
يعجب ولا عادل بس انا انا بحس انه يعني في
جزء في جزئيه شوي مبهمه او خاطئه لانه طب
ما هو الرجل الذي ياخذ اي مخاطر او يغامر
ويخسر مش بس لحاله هو يعني في اطار
العائله مش لحاله رح يتحمل الخساره مع
زوجته راح تتحملها ومعها رح تتحمل هذه
الخساره هي ايضا وراح تعاني مثل ما هو
يعاني عندما يعني تترتب امور فعليه على
سبيل المثال قرار تغيير العمل دائما بكون
يعني عند الرجال في جراه اكثر من المراه
ودائما لما يكون في نقاش بين الزوجين على
انه الرجل بده يغير الشغل دائما بتقول له
طيب استقر رتب زبط علاقات
بتحب الاستقرار اذا هذا تحليل الدكتور
محمد فريج اختصاصي العلاج النفسي حول هذه
الدراسه واللي ياكد انه الرجل يتحمل ما
شكرا شكرا
اخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على
اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات